hey youtubers is Charlie so earlier on
Twitter I asked which video you guys
wanted me to do next
overwhelmingly spider-man marvel since
there's been a lot in the news about
this what I'm actually gonna do is my
top 5 actors I think would make an
awesome Peter Parker I'll explain what
needs to happen in order for this to
work in order for them to share the
character and I'll explain some of the
bigger reasons about why it probably
won't work out I know it sounds simple
in theory but when you start breaking
down who has the rights to what and who
has the say and how much money is
involved it almost sounds impossible
it's a miracle that any movies get made
in Hollywood so new spider-man actors
why do we need new spider-man actors
Andrew Garfield is spider-man right now
apparently Marvel not a huge fan of
Andrew Garfield all the Sony documents
that leaked about them talking to Marvel
about sharing the character involved
getting rid of Andrew Garfield I think
that's just because Marvel wants a fresh
start they don't want any of the sony
spider-man films to be canon so if you
see spider-man in the Marvel verse it'll
be a brand new spin on the character I
guess puns are a big part of spider-man
so maybe I should do more of that
how many puns do you think they could
fit into one Marvel film before it
exploded so long shot spider-man does
work out it happens at Marvel it becomes
another reboot I don't think that Marvel
or Sony cares about the recency of with
which spider-man was already rebooted
like the time between spider-man and the
amazing spider-man when Andrew Garfield
took the role they probably don't care
about that even though it seems totally
weird the real issue is what's gonna
happen with the future of the spider-man
franchise after he comes to the Marvel
verse is Marvel only gonna be allowed to
make spider-man films will Sony be able
to continue to make solo spider-man
films two really big questions that I'll
get to in a sec either way it means
brand-new actor sorry Andrew Garfield
and this doesn't even get into the Miles
Morales stuff there's a whole lot of
drama with that so top five actors so
what I'm gonna do for each of these is
like my thumbs up why I think it'd be a
good idea and thumbs down why I don't
think it worked so here we go starting
with number five Dylan O'Brien thumbs up
he has john r experience and most of the
characters he's played have been Peter
Parker types so he knows the drill and
no matter which Marvel film spider-man
appears in it's probably only going to
be a supporting role so he won't be
completely responsible for carrying the
story
he's got name level recognition even
though I consider him kind of like
be level blockbuster Star Marvel tends
to go after actors on the rise like he
is so they don't have to pay them as
much Robert Downey jr. is the only
exception to that so the thumbs down on
Dylan even though spider-man would only
be a supporting character a bad choice
of actor could sync the movie and Dylan
isn't really proven on the level of what
these big Marvel films have been held to
no matter how much we seem on screen
spider-man always gonna be a really huge
deal so even if the actor doesn't speak
a lot or get a lot of screen time it's
still really important number 4 slightly
safer bet Ansel Elgort thumbs up he's
great with drama and spider-man drama is
the core of civil war in the comic books
Marvel isn't doing the comic book
storyline for civil war but they can't
graft some of that into Avengers
infinity war anytime he's with the
Avengers spider-man is a boy being taken
advantage of by older heroes and
I do think that spider-man in the Marvel
verse be a younger version of the
spider-man character
he's like the impressionable little
brother so if they want to stay true to
that he is the right age like a very
young twentysomething spider-man he even
looks like he could still be in high
school if they want to go that young if
they want to go super young thumbs down
on Angela the only real experience he
has in action movies like Marvel type
action is the divergent trilogy and he
hasn't really done a lot of action in
those movies he also hasn't really shown
he could pull off the twitchy
hyperactive quality that Peter Parker
has number 3 moving up the ladder a
little bit Anton Yelchin thumbs up
he has strong indie drama experience and
big blockbuster genre experience Chekov
kind of is the Peter Parker of the
enterprise at least in the new JJ Abrams
films plus he's even wearing spider-man
red now thumbs down and this is a big
thumbs down there could be huge
scheduling conflicts with the Star Trek
sequels they haven't set a date for Star
Trek 3 but it's definitely happening
after that though there is potential for
them riding in a new cast or at least
writing check off out so that he'd be
free to do other really big movies
typically big movies can shoot for up to
6 months not including the time they
allocate for reshoots and the time that
the actors have to spend traveling all
over the world promoting films number
two crossing the streams a little bit
more nicholas hoult thumbs up all the
same reasons as Anton Yelchin I feel
like Nicholas Hoult has a little more
on-screen presence he's just shown he
can carry a big movie just a little bit
more than
ha Yelchin but the big thumbs down same
reason is check off the x-men franchises
in the middle of making apocalypse
they'll be shooting soon small upside
the cast of those movies is so enormous
they could easily write beasts out of
the films without a lot of explanation
to leave nicholas hoult free to do other
big movies usually having too many
characters in a film is a bad thing but
in the case of x-men it means that some
of those actors can have more time to do
other big films and my number one pick
pretty much a long shot but Jamie Dornan
so big thumbs up he's getting ready to
be the biggest star on the planet once
Fifty Shades of Grey comes out next year
just you wait it'll be crazy he can
carry a big film he's not super
expensive because he's still considered
an up-and-comer and he has a lot of
genre experience if any of you guys are
big once upon a time fans so thumbs down
and big thumbs down he's probably too
old to play Peter Parker as Marvel would
want to use the character no way he can
pull off impressionable youth living
with Thor Iron Man and Captain America
next door Civil War for example is like
a superhero breakup and Peter Parker is
like their child who gets caught in the
crossfire no way Jamie Dornan can pull
off that kind of energy with the other
Avengers very big long shot but if they
decide to go with an older spider-man
then it would totally work and he's
currently not signed to other mega
franchises yet although they're probably
totally gonna go for a Fifty Shades
sequel just because that movie's gonna
make a billion dollars let me know who
some of you guys Pixar for a new Peter
Parker they don't even have to be
realistic just anybody you think would
make an awesome Peter Parker so next big
question what about Miles Morales what
about that Spider Man they wouldn't have
to recast Andrew Garfield they could
just use a totally different actor the
answer to that is because the producers
avi arad and Matt Tomac they currently
control the fate of spider-man films it
gets really confusing with the legalese
but until a V Arad passes the project on
to another producer Peter Parker will be
the only spider-man we ever see and
that's from his mouth he said as long as
he's in control of that franchise Peter
Parker is gonna be the only spider-man
we ever see that being said I think that
Marvel is open to the idea of Miles
Morales I mean they did ultimate
spider-man so they were already open to
it in the comics I think they'd be
willing to try it out on screen
especially if he's only a supporting
character it's always a lot easier for
them to
risky things if it doesn't have to carry
a movie if it were solo film if it were
solo spider-man film it'd be a different
story so the next big question say Sony
and Marvel work out a deal in like the
next couple weeks and they allow Marvel
to use the spider-man character what's
gonna happen what's more we're gonna do
with that so the easy answer is he gets
introduced in a supporting role in civil
war then becomes a full-blown Avenger
sometime during the first infinity war
film like a battlefield promotion the
thumbs down on that is that they're
probably not gonna reach a deal in time
for him to get into civil war
at least for a meaningful role civil war
will start shooting right after Avengers
2 age of Ultron is released in theaters
they're not gonna start shooting while
two of their biggest stars are out
promoting another film so if you really
want to get down to it if we don't hear
about any new actors being cast as
spider-man before say like April it's
totally not gonna happen and that's what
they would do it they would announce you
know which actors are in the running
then they would officially announce okay
so this actor is the new Spider Man and
then they would just say he's going to
appear in X film it'd be just like with
all the other Marvel films you know this
actor cast as this character in this
film the other thumbs down and this
isn't quite as big of a thumbs down is
that they won't be able to do any
version of the comic-book Civil War
storyline they've already written that
script it has absolutely nothing to do
with identity it's just one of the next
big changes that Marvel is made to their
movies from the comic books they did the
same thing with Avengers 2 with Ultron
and divisions backstory it's just one of
the issues that comes with making big
films like that so the next big thing
this actually fascinates me is what's
gonna happen
with the future of the spider-man
franchise like the spider-man solo films
if they give the character to marble
sony's gonna want to keep making their
own spider-man films they make way too
much money for them not to do it but if
they give the rights to Marvel that
might get complicated down the road with
profit sharing with solo films plus
there's the issue of the number of comic
book films being released by 2017 Marvel
has three films on the schedule already
that does not include any of the Star
Wars films or any of the DC films just
for example they'll be guardians to Thor
3 and black panther that's all in the
same year after that dear after that
another 3 Marvel films there's a point
at which people will say this blows see
you guys later this is why what I'm
hoping to see is them just absolutely
wait to use spider-man till phase 4 and
then
shehram then maybe cameo maybe
full-blown Avenger that would give Sony
time to get its together and the
Marvel verse will have already changed
quite a bit by that time most of the
actors contracts will be up and they can
either cast new actors or they can Rio
so it'll be much easier for them to roll
in a brand new spider-man so this is a
pretty good place to jump off here's my
big question for you guys let me know in
the comments would you rather see
spider-man right now like in a small
cameo in Avengers infinity war or would
you be willing to wait five or six years
to see him in like a really big role in
a phase four movie I really would like
to see them wait just a little bit so
that they could do something canonical
something from the comics rather than
awkwardly kind of which him into one of
the already overstuffed Avengers films
seriously they're gonna be so many
characters and Avengers infinity war
adding spider-man in will not make it
better right now spider-man in the
Marvel verse is a really fascinating
idea it just does not seem like a
reality but everybody gets their
Christmas wish so be sure to use it
wisely in related news I'm working on
some age of Ultron videos so be sure to
subscribe to get those feel free to
leave me a request for other Marvel
videos lots of really interesting stuff
happening in the Marvel verse right now
they're actually they're probably pretty
close to announcing who they're Captain
Marvel is who the female actor they
picked is I'd expect them to announce
that sometime before Avengers 2 next
year so in the meantime if you're on
your mobile phone or on a tablet there's
new links up here you can click on this
the same as the links over here but
click here to learn what's going on with
Captain America's Civil War right now
and click here to learn all about Thor 3
in the Ragnarok story that it's based on
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I will see you guys
tomorrow
you